comme prévu la pression va s'accentuer
encore un peu plus sur les non vaccinés
d'ici deux mois les tests de dépistage
au coville 19 ne seront plus remboursés
par la sécurité sociale sauf sur
prescription médicale
les tests ne protège pas les tests à
répétition n'empêche pas d'aller à
l'hôpital et de contaminer fortement
d'ici mi-octobre à chacun aura le temps
de s'organiser et de prendre ses
responsabilités nous prenons également
les nôtres par responsabilités
comprenaient se faire vacciner pour
continuer à avoir un semblant de vie
normale se faire un ciné un resto un
musée les plus réfractaires au vaccin
vont donc devoir payer de leur poche ou
alors guérir d'une récente contamination
coville 19 pour posséder un pass à
lithaire impasse sans quoi il n'est plus
possible de faire grand chose
aujourd'hui une france à deux vitesses
complètement assumé par le président de
la république si nous n'avions pas le
passé n'était aujourd'hui on serait
obligé de refermer
c'est à dire de faire porter la
contrainte sur tout le monde avec le
pass à lithaire on l'a fait porter
uniquement sur celles et ceux qui ne se
sont pas encore fait vacciner et en leur
demandant de se tester pour protéger les
autres les tests ne protège pas du virus
le vaccin oui les tests coûte cher les
vaccins beaucoup moins ce sont en
substance les arguments formulés par les
pros backs la sécurité sociale ne peut
pas continuer à dépenser un milliard
d'euros tous les mois pour faire des
tests à des gens qui refusent le vaccin
le risque d'une fracture sociale n'est
pas non plus à exclure et pour cause
elle certains peuvent se permettre de
payer ces tests d'autres non il faudra
par exemple le comptait une quarantaine
d'euros pour un test pcr 25 pour un test
antigénique la fin de la gratuité des
tests pourrait-elle avoir un impact
négatif sur le suivi de l'épidémie
certains s'interrogent si on faisait
payer les gens on aurait aucune idée de
l'incidence de la population de la
manière dont le virus touche la
population c'est d'ailleurs une question
que j'ai posée au conseil scientifique
quels sont les indicateurs après pour
surveiller la population
ce n'est pas simplement avec des tests
payer de temps en temps par ci par là
qu'on saura exactement ce qui se passe
sur le territoire autre question cette
mesure est-elle
anticonstitutionnelle parce que lorsque
les sages se sont prononcés sur le
projet de loi sanitaire le 5 août
dernier les tests de dépistage était
encore présenté comme gratuit alors si
le pass sanitaire peut être contraignant
il restait tout de même plus ou moins
accessibles à tous la loi qui va servir
de base à ces textes a été jugé conforme
à la constitution
sauf les exceptions qu'on connaît cette
annonce ne peut pas remettre en question
a posteriori la constitutionnalité de la
loi le conseil constitutionnel ne peut
donc pas faire marche arrière mais il
existe toutefois des recours dans ce cas
là ce sera au conseil d'état de plancher
sur la question car c'est lui qui fait
autorité sur les décrets d'application
de la loi